[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum again thank you for
listening uh if this is your first time
and you're a big matt walsh fan if you
don't know him he's been in tons of
stuff
uh
co-created the upright citizens brigade
tons of great stuff he's a funny man
you're going to learn a lot
very interesting but i hope that you'll
uh subscribe to the podcast
and uh you'll keep listening subscribe
you can listen anywhere apple spotify
you can watch on youtube please
subscribe write a review it helps the
podcast immensely thank you for tuning
in and making this podcast your choice
for this week ryan hello hello
how you doing buddy i'm doing okay how
are you doing house therapy pen that's
fine yeah yeah that's what's happening
with me i think my anxiety is getting a
little bit better but uh
still working on it man still working on
i just had a big uh
patron
zoom call with the top tier patrons and
patreon is a place where people support
the podcast it's patreon.com inside of
you i'll message you back if you join
um they support the podcast there's
different tiers and different things and
perks and you get your name shouted out
at the end of the podcast and lots of
other great stuff so join patreon.com
inside of you um it's cool um but uh you
know on the zoom last night with the
patrons we were talking about our
anxieties and how it you know everyone
was really like hey this podcast really
helps me and it makes me feel good that
you know
i'm helping some
because it feels almost inadvertent like
i don't think i'm helping people you're
just talking to people sure but then
things come out like their anxiety their
depression and their mental health and
so you know and especially you you're
you're uh forthcoming you're uh
you know you speak your mind you tell us
how it is how you're doing that's right
i'm known for just you know speaking
truth
you do
truth bombs you dropped some facts
people love ryan that's me they do i get
a lot of messages saying they love ryan
i got
people are starting to follow me on
from talk phil i think yeah do we
promote me for some reason i i always
promote i'm sorry everyone no thank you
for supporting ryan teows and following
him thank you for supporting the
talkville podcast if you don't know that
we're doing that uh tom welling and i my
co-star from smallville he was clark
kent of course we're doing a re-watch
podcast ryan is here um and we watch
every episode from the beginning and
then we critique it we talk about it we
tell stories and the fans call in and
it's a it's becoming a really cool thing
and uh we're really excited so uh
subscribe to talk phil as well um
asking you to do a lot subscribe to
inside of you the handles for inside of
you are at inside of you podcast on the
uh instagram and facebook at insideipod
on the twitter and then if you want to
subscribe to talkville it's at talkville
podcast i think on instagram and
facebook
and that
talkvillepod on twitter maybe just check
it out but follow us everywhere uh try
to listen to both podcasts if you can
and support um i appreciate you uh tom
and i welling will be doing a smallville
nights and a convention
in uh boston this coming weekend friday
night is smallville nights we do this
event private event we read scenes from
smallville i put on a bald cap he puts
on the flannel shirt it's uh
it's a lot of fun so fan expo boston
this weekend um hopefully you're there
hopefully you'll join us also um
go to the inside of you online store
there's tons of merch there's there's
smallville stuff scripts signed by me
lunch boxes small the lunch boxes inside
you tumblers and coffee mugs and a bunch
of great stuff there's still so many uh
so many cool things on there so go to
the inside of you online store and also
of course
the band sunspin.com our new album's
coming out like in a month or two so get
merch at sunspin.com you can book the
band you can book a zoom with the band
that's me
and we'll zoom with each other we'll
talk we'll we'll
converse we'll enjoy other words for
talking talking and conversing at the
same speaking there it's just the bigger
word i tried to use to
sound a little smarter um i'm convinced
thank you thank you i just try to get by
um
all is well
uh great podcast today thanks for
joining us again
and um hey this is uh this is a good one
i know that you really enjoyed this one
this guy's been in everything oh he's in
everything and he's every time you see
him on screen you're like oh this scene
is gonna be funny yeah he makes a lot of
cameos and
it's amazing and what a sweet man oh
yeah what a sweet man i had him right
here and uh
right here in studio and it's always fun
to have the guests in studio we've got a
lot of great guests coming up just
interviewed john heater and will wheaton
and there's a lot of great guests coming
up so please continue to listen and
support the podcast couldn't do it
without you guys and without further ado
let's get inside of matt walsh it's my
point of view
you're listening to inside of you
with michael rosenbaum
[Music]
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
i've uh you've mentioned everything i've
had a flourishing career as a character
actor this is my camera work to this one
or talk to you michael you can just talk
to me
do you prefer michael or mike probably
you know my mike sounds collegiate like
you're you know the college you're like
hey mike's throwing a bash okay
you're a grown up i feel well you're 50.
i just turned 50 you saw the big uh
balloons when you walked in
um
what do i need to know about my 50s
oh i'm ahead of you um because you told
me you're ahead of me my wife threw me
maybe the most glorious party ever of my
lifetime she i was in baltimore working
she organized
an incredible surprise party with like
my buddies from high school
uh the people i was work like the cast i
was working with like all of my family
members they all flew out to baltimore
from various parts of the country
and then kept me in the dark meanwhile i
was planning
my own birthday party with people i was
working with and everyone's like imagine
you're in on the surprise and i'm going
hey so michael i'm gonna have some
people for dinner and you're like okay
i'll be there like everyone's lying to
me right because they know morgan has
set up this grand surprise and then it
was at this really cool like
bar pizza place with video games and old
skee-ball games was incredible and i was
completely and utterly surprised never
really i had one other surprise party in
my life but this was just
lights out and my favorite moment where
one of my most memorable moments is
walking in the door and my mother was
there
my mom doesn't like to travel did you
even came out did you cry no
i just turned to her i'm like what the
[ __ ] are you doing here
but it wasn't it sounded mean but it was
more like i couldn't contextualize any
of it it didn't
dawn on me that it was a fully organized
surprise party
and that she was also in on it yeah like
when you're in those moments yeah how
did that feel
oh my god it was so wonderful and so
like overwhelming and
you know just incredibly festive and
you know just we
went crazy all night it was so fun do
you know i've never had a surprise party
no one's ever done a surprise for me
really
yeah
well you're sort of putting it out there
i'm sort of putting it out there ryan
it's too late now my 50 no but you have
next birthday it would be a surprise if
it was after your 50th wouldn't it be
yeah anything would be a surprise i just
no one's ever thought you know i guess
because i organized a lot of my own
stuff like you were saying you organize
your own kind of thing like let's get
together let's do this and people think
oh he is he does it he does everything
but it'd be nice if somebody took the
reins
it is and i'm
not super organized but for that for the
50th i was i was like well i got to do
something i'm out here i'm not home so i
started organizing things and i even
like they even had the lady who the the
woman who ran this nice restaurant i
liked in on it so i would say i need to
change that reservation to 12. i need to
change it to 14 and every time she's
like okay i'm writing it down 14
and like no there's no resume morgan was
ahead of the game
i probably owe her a lights out surprise
party which i'm not
looking forward to because it'll make me
so anxious and it won't be as good as
hers but i will try to do it really
going to try and throw a surprise party
at some point yeah to kind of return the
favor that's nice yeah but what are the
50s like do you notice any difference do
you notice a change i mean you've also
got three kids you're married you've got
you know a lot going on i mean do you do
you feel more overwhelmed in your 50s do
you feel more laid-back do you kind of
know who you are what is it about the
50s that i could look forward to or not
look forward to well i can only
characterize my own 50s and none of it
was like uh driven by the decade
and my like assessment of like okay
where should i be in my 50s it was more
of a natural like i think
the first thing i'm probably like more
chill
like you talk about chill i think i'm
just
less uh eager to
go out and do things necessarily i'm
just more chill i'm happy to be at home
i'm happy to boot the kids
uh i've probably like
toned down my like energy of partying
like by a hundred percent were you a
partier i think so yeah i'd like to go
out a lot like i lived in new york
forever and uh
i don't know and i did a lot of like
shows like we were always like doing a
comedy show and you go out for a couple
of years after not
partying nothing hard or anything but i
feel like festive evenings were like
once a week sure right i don't even
think i'd do that anymore you know
yeah do you feel worse after a drink the
next day you could feel if it's a drink
yeah but i don't like i said i kind of
put it all down like i really don't do
anything i used to smoke weed i don't
smoke weed anymore i really is it just
because you just don't feel like doing
it or is it i think it was a cure the
booze was um
i don't recover so it was like i don't
like i i still have drinks like i'll
have a beer too but i never go hard
anymore like right ever
and
for weed it was more curiosity of like
am i like
smoking too much so i just kind of put
it down
and i enjoyed not doing it for a while
and so i've continued that right if that
makes sense it does make sense yeah well
look you've done so much work as we were
just talking about i mean
you know we got this new movie press
play which i watched the trailer for and
it looks really sweet like it looks like
a tearjerker yes it is it is the guy i
have a very small part but the guy
greg bjorkman who directed it he came
out of that camp like the the fault in
our stars did you ever see that yeah
yeah yeah i loved that movie he was sort
of mentored by the guy behind that and
so it's very much of that energy where
like people are having these wonderful
conversations about life and it's about
love and
and so it has that energy not that it's
the same movie in any way so but that's
a great movie to reference well i don't
know that they're probably apples and
oranges because i haven't seen that one
in a while but the feel yeah the feel is
there yeah
i think that's the genre perhaps maybe
they were trying to get and greg's a
wonderful guy and so uh i said sure i'll
do it so and you look mike mckinnon talk
from veep we were just quoting you
uh you know two emmy award nominations i
mean
you've done so many movies what does
that get you anyways but seriously
i was nominated for a uh
i won a saturn award and my friends
immediately said well better than the
uranus award michael you know that's the
kind of [ __ ] that i what's the saturn
award it was kind of a sci-fi it was
when smallville just came out and it was
like a newcomer best newcomer and it was
like i was i was there with spielberg
and i took a picture with spielberg and
it was the saturn awards it was a nice
thing
was the saturn awards its own ceremony
or was it inside the emmys no it's its
own awards its own thing did saturn cars
run this
i don't know okay i don't think so i
don't think they did okay i'm just
curious i didn't know but look you've
done all these things i mean the
founding member of the upright citizens
were great which i think i saw is it
possible i saw you in new york in 97
yeah very possible i think you were
were you with three arts managers i was
with dave becky yes that's how i kind of
knew you loosely we arrived out of
chicago the four of us and so
becky was uh my manager at the time and
i feel like i would see you in the
office or
whatever we would have crossover through
that and new york was also a small scene
right yeah i mean
look i look at your career and i then i
go back and i look at like what you were
doing in high school when you were like
a tight end in high school let's go
ahead and oh my god you were a back up
tight in in high school so you take this
off my wikipedia you're the second
interviewer are you popular
i was popular i was like uh i had like
six or seven really good mates that i
always rolled with and i played a little
bit of sports and i worked at a
country club and
uh so i guess i was popular and i was
like a class clown type i was disruptive
in class which
uh i was probably looking for attention
yet not knowing how to channel i hadn't
really discovered theater yet so i was
sort of like understanding like what
performing is and figuring that out too
because you had how many brothers and
sisters i have uh three older brothers
and three younger sisters so i'm one of
seven were you in the middle yes
does that explain anything do you think
i think there is the birth order i buy
into the birth order uh personality
traits that if you're
surrounded by many siblings and you're
kind of stuck in the middle
you uh probably need to find ways to get
attention or to separate yourself from
the pack and i think that definitely
applies to some elements my personality
and one thing i learned about middle
children which you guys might find
interesting is i recently took a ghost
tour in savannah
and during the yellow fever epidemic
people did it was kind of like early
covert they didn't know how it spread
but people were dying left and right and
so if you had an uncle
who died you had to get the body to the
graveyard and you would like knock on
this crypt and like put it in this crypt
or whatever
wow they would always send the middle
child to go do that because they were
expendable you wouldn't send the oldest
and you wouldn't send the young why was
the middle kid suddenly expendable
because everybody agreed that they're
not going to be exceptional
they're just like the baby is the baby
and the oldest especially if it's a boy
is like the future and the estate's
going to go to him but the kids in the
middle were expendable
that's terrifying it's a true thing
which i found interesting wow
and now a word from our sponsor better
help
one of my favorite sponsors by the way
uh ryan what does burnout mean to you
not like you see these guys that are
burnouts
that's different well it's completely
different just uh being
depleted depleted of energy overworked
overworked not making enough time for
yourself yep have you guys felt burnt
out i i know i have i constantly feel
burnt out
it feels to me like
i just don't have energy to do anything
and you know you've got to take time for
yourself you've got to pay attention to
your body your mind and and better help
is there for us ryan i know still uses
better help a lot of my listeners yep
listen to better help
life can be overwhelming
it sure can and many people are burned
out without even knowing it symptoms can
include lack of motivation irritability
fatigue and more we associate burnout
with work but that's not the only cause
any of our roles in life can lead us to
feel burned out
better help online therapy wants to
remind you to prioritize yourself i
don't know how many times i say this on
the podcast be good to you be good to
yourself
talking with someone can help you figure
out what's causing stress in your life
i know
that i get so in my head
that i sometimes don't know what to do
next i don't i'm overwhelmed with life
i'm overwhelmed and i just tend to go
back in the bedroom and just fall on my
bed and try to sleep it off
instead of dealing with my [ __ ]
if i could say that i don't think better
help it cares it's real stuff here i'm
talking about
but um
talking to a therapist talking to
someone
someone who's objective someone who can
you know who listen to you who's a
professional it helps it really truly
helps and um
don't take my word for it take ryan's
word for it take
take uh all the patrons and all the
people around the world that use better
help yeah take their word for it yeah
um better help is customized online
therapy that offers video phone and even
live chat sessions with your therapist
so you don't have to see anyone on
camera if you don't want to it's much
more affordable than in-person therapy i
can tell you that especially living out
here in california you can be matched
with a therapist in under 48 hours and
our listeners get 10 percent off
their first month at betterhelp.com
inside
that's better help
better h-e-l-p
dot com slash
inside
inside of you is brought to you by bambi
when running a business your employees
can create all kinds of interesting
situations like getting complaints
because someone on the team always
smells horrible you better talk to bambi
somebody isn't showing up when they're
supposed to
talk to bambi
with bambi get access to your own
dedicated hr manager starting at just 99
per month they're available by phone
email and real-time chat so on-boarding
and terminations run smoothly team
members reach peak performance and your
business stays compliant with changing
hr regulations and with bambi's hr
autopilot you'll automate important hr
practices like setting policies training
and feedback i think it's vital to have
someone else
take care of this for you these are
significant problems and bambi is there
for you they're a us-based person
dedicated to your business giving you
access to the hr expertise and personal
touch you need
folks hr issues can kill you one
complaint against your company can turn
your world upside down you spend way too
much time dealing with hr when you
should be spending your time on making a
profit bambi helps small business owners
with their most complex hr issues and
employment nuances across all 50 states
helps you implement hr policies to
protect your business and give you hr
peace of mind hr managers can easily
cost 80 grand a year but bambi starts at
just 99
per month schedule your free
conversation today to see how much bambi
can take off your plate visit bambi
b-a-m-b-e
dot com slash inside right now spelled
b-a-m-b-e-e
dot com
slash inside bambi.com slash inside
inside you is brought to you by wondery
i learned so much from wandery ryan uh
they've got
uh great podcasts
like ours
and they talk about really interesting
stuff like i learned so much about the
the lives the tumultuous lives of the
world's elite and what goes on behind
closed doors and like oh just the big
stuff they just tell really interesting
stories uh even the rich is a podcast
from wandery that tells jaw-dropping
stories about the tumultuous lives of
the world's elite from the greatest
family dynasties to pop culture
superstars having unimaginable wealth
unlocks a world of which most of us
could only dream
but once you get past the red carpet
galas and private jet vacations there's
a darker side power and wealth come with
an entirely different set of problems so
unique and demanding for once you'll be
glad you're not in their shoes
in a recent season even the rich
explored the downside of fame for elton
john whose meteoric rise was checkered
with soul-crushing periods of isolation
then there's patty hearst a newspaper
heiress kidnapped by a guerrilla
organization and forced to commit
unspeakable acts there's also seasons
devoted to all the glitz glamour and
behind the scenes drama that goes into
being the kardashians and the hiltons
they all dreamed of being on top of the
world having no idea that maintaining it
would be harder than they ever imagined
it really is hard to imagine people that
are so rich and wealthy being depressed
ryan
and you know but watching their world
it's it it's kind of understandable it's
like it always tells you that no matter
how much money you have it doesn't make
you happy you have to be happy
before that
and so you see these worlds
you know crumbling and like
all these horrible things that happen to
people and they grow up with rich
families and they're out partying all
the time and they're
wasting their lives away and they just
have no direction and how do they
survive and so all these stories are
pretty pretty badass
listen to even the rich on apple
podcasts amazon music or wherever you
get your podcasts you can listen ad free
by joining wondery plus in apple
podcasts or the wandery app
what was it like growing up though with
so many siblings was it uh did you feel
like you were the forgot because i
always felt like i always forgot my
brother actually said this to me he woke
up
and he wrote down his thoughts he's like
hey i had those nightmares and i just
wrote down all these thoughts and i just
realized how you know ignored you were
or during our childhood and i go why
what during your childhood yeah he's
like he's like nobody paid any attention
to you i just felt like no one ever
listened to you
i was like wow somebody finally gets me
but that's good you got that at an early
age what do you mean your brother
revealed that now he revealed that to me
about a month oh sorry i thought this
was when you were kids
it was kind of startling yeah to you
know
was it like that for you was it because
there's so many kids that you know that
mom and dad kind of overlooked you and
that kind of made you a little
rambunctious and rebel and yeah i think
unconsciously that was there i mean
there was definitely a foundation of
love and my parents are great my dad's
long past but and my mom was fantastic
and
she had a good childhood i had a
fundamentally wonderfully childhood i
really did like i was loved and there's
also like
in some ways my older brother i can
think of instances where
he served as a father figure like if i
was crying he would take me and he would
walk me around the block and he would
talk me down you know what i mean so
there's like in big families it's not
uncommon for one of the siblings to sort
of serve in moments
as a parent you know so yeah i got that
too i feel like i've taken over that
role as i've gotten older i've been the
parent to everybody so how many siblings
you have or just i had my mom had two
kids from her first marriage and then my
she married my dad when she was 23 with
a five and a seven year old he was 18
okay and then they got married and then
they had me a year later and then my
brother five years later
and and you're sort of uh a parent to a
lot of these siblings oh yeah yeah i'm
sort of a parent to my mom i am a parent
of mine
yeah and it gets exhausting i mean you
didn't really have to do that did you i
mean you had the love you had the they
acted like your parents like the parents
should act because i think that's what
happens is that uh you take over the
parental when they got divorced my mom
was suicidal and uh would call me up and
i'm trying to do a job and i'm like look
can you not kill yourself today i got a
big i got a long day today you know and
it was it was
it was tough
but i always look at people like oh you
must have had the same thing but i like
hearing about normal experiences where
your mom was your mom she didn't always
ask you for money your dad was your dad
he didn't how how was that
uh i guess
in that it was all i knew it was great
like it was wonderful like uh
yeah we were just like sort of like a
lower middle class middle-class family
in chicagoland yeah outside chicago and
uh i liked having older brothers because
they sort of
looked out for you as needed of course i
got like beat up by them occasionally
like when i was little
and uh but they did look out for you and
then
having sisters was cool and uh i think
it it was great i mean i don't really
have any sense of what you know because
and we all get along still
which is shocking wow and it was
unconditional love your parents were
like happy with whatever you were doing
they wanted you to be happy
that's a big question because i know you
weren't you weren't into acting and all
that stuff at first you didn't start
improving and all the uh all the
you know serious acting stuff until
later right you were like studying
psychology i was a psychology student in
college yeah i thought i was going to be
a psychologist and i was i was curious
about that and i went to europe for a
year because i didn't know what i wanted
to do and then so i was searching a lot
but yeah i think there was definitely
unconditional love and to their credit
like
they came and saw some of the worst
shows in comedy history
and they brought friends and some of it
was vulgar and i'm like oh my god why
did him and my brother's like why did
you invite mom and they're not gonna
like this they were old-fashioned you
know
orthodox catholic mom and dad they
weren't they weren't gonna like a lot of
what we were doing in the early days so
what would they say after a show that
you bombed sometimes it would be like my
favorite my mom's so tough she's amazing
like you have to read underneath
uh like the fact that she shows up she
loves me you know what i mean i don't
need her a hug because it wasn't a lot
of hugs it was like there were
uh the affection physical affection was
never really there but it was okay but
she would say things after show like
well you're getting better like that was
her take on the show
well that's that's nice yeah it is nice
but it's a little underhanded like that
wasn't a great show
i don't i don't think i'll come back
and you knew you're getting better yeah
and you knew when it's a bad show you
know 100 you feel it i remember the
first sketch show
i did with a group called department of
works guys right out of college or like
five of us living in a two bedroom in
chicago long story short it was i think
it was like a two hour and twenty minute
show with no intermission
like what were we thinking we had no
sense of what an audience has to sit
there and my parents god bless them
invited like
12 people to the show so they had dinner
before and they're like maddie's doing
my dad was very enthusiastic about me
being an actor really yeah maddie's
doing a play i think he had a penchant
for like
being an actor but he there was no world
where he could have been like he had
seven kids he was never gonna be an
actor see we were the opposite my dad i
remember i did a play and i go hey i was
in college and we went to denny's
afterwards and
i just remember saying
i'm gonna be an actor and he said eat
your steak
that was just disappointed or what i
think he was just like what are you
doing you're not gonna make it as an
actor my my my whole family was like
what are you what are the odds
come on what are we doing here what am i
putting you in school for what are you
going to school for this is what you're
doing but you had a
a cheerleader in your father
but this was after college really right
yeah i think so and i think part of it
was i was the only one in the family
truly pursuing it so i was sort of like
this oddity who didn't fit in so i think
the curiosity of it was like well i got
one kid who's not going into the
straight world in a way you know what i
mean like i think i had that
freedom and i was sort of misfitting
fitty forever you know they always
thought you were funny
funny appreciated comedy uh
goofy
concern for me at times my grandpa's
like i don't know what's wrong with that
kid
that's like my my grandfather would say
the same thing he would look at me and
go you're a nut yeah
you're not and he meant it like i love
you but yeah there's something wrong
with you yeah there was that element yes
which is like
in some ways
i don't know what sort of pathology we
had but i'm sure there was something
there but what what happened what was it
you go to austria or something and
you're studying psychology and you're
what what was the turnaround what was
like this is not what i need to be doing
what inspired you to get into this
inspired well
one thing was doing a variety show in
high school we got to be
writing sketches about the teachers and
making fun of them and one teacher
really got upset with me and was not
happy with how we characterized her but
the sort of bug
i got bit by the bug and the story i
want to know how you characterized her
name was uh penny she's probably god
bless her she was an english teacher and
anyone who teaches is a saint like
absolutely so i was a challenging
student i'm sure
and uh she was just really strict and
she i think she probably had some like
bipolar stuff happening she would just
get
livid and insane about something like
one time she gave us candy and i didn't
like it and i threw it in the trash can
and then she found it in the trash can
and she was crushed like somebody had
taken her gift and like smashed it
intentionally and i wasn't doing it to
hurt her feelings i just like i didn't
like it so she would overreact
emotionally so i think we characterized
her as a psychotic person and an
insanely mean woman so wow uh so that
was one uh character so anyways that was
the bug for
performing and then the sort of
reception that you get like people like
the next day in school like god you're
so funny that was so great you're like
really
inside of you is brought to you by
shopify don't know what i would do with
that shopify boy does shopify make it
easy for me to have a a website a uh you
know a place where i can sell merch
to my
awesome listeners uh i started out on
shopify with like a t-shirt and now i
have probably 50 items and they make it
so easy to just manage i'm telling you i
can't do anything folks
shopify is unbelievable you can see what
product is doing good what product isn't
doing good how many uh how many uh of
each product you have left there's just
so much it tells you how much you're
making for the month compared to the
last month it's all right there at your
fingertips shopify gives entrepreneurs
the resources once reserved for big
business
so upstarts startups and established
businesses alike can sell everywhere
synchronize online and in-person sales
and effortlessly stay informed scaling
your business is a journey of endless
possibility yes believe me again this
podcast we started selling
nothing and i had no idea how to use it
and then i realized it's so easy to use
and i'm not stopping there because
success is a million milestones on a
forever evolving path i love how shopify
has the tools and resources that make it
easy for any business to succeed from
down the street to around the globe
reach customers online and across social
networks with an ever-growing suite of
channel integrations and apps including
facebook instagram tech talk pinterest
and more gain insights as you grow with
detailed reporting of conversion rates
profit margins and beyond more than a
store shopify grows with you this is
possibility powered by shopify
go to shopify.com
inside all lowercase for a free 14-day
trial and get full access to shopify's
entire suite of features grow your
business with shopify today go to
shopify.com
inside right now shopify.com
inside inside of you is brought to you
by geico geico asks how would you love a
chance to save some money on insurance
of course you would after all who
doesn't love a great deal right and when
it comes to great rates on insurance for
all the things in your life
geico can help like with insurance for
your car truck motorcycle boat and rv
even help with homeowners condo or
renter's coverage you could save even
more with a special discount when you
bundle your coverages plus add the easy
to use geico mobile app available
24-hour roadside assistance and more and
choosing to switch to geico becomes an
easy choice switch today and see all the
ways you could save with great rates and
discounts it's easy simply go to
geico.com to get a rate quote or contact
your local agent and get started seeing
how much you could save
i like the
somebody acknowledges you you know it
was for me it was i did grease
in high school like everybody and i
remember this popular kid i've talked
about it before chris pro
and he walked by me in the and i was the
shortest kid in my high school
i i wasn't popular
and he looked at me goes
you were really funny last night
and then he [ __ ] off
and i go
oh my god i found it not being me is the
way to go
being someone else portraying of you
know being a different part being in it
it did something somehow
resonated so i think that was where
that that insecure weird little me
kind of said hey you're going in the
closet and i'm going to take over
you know interesting yeah well that
affirmation is what
you were probably seeking right that
elevated like
you know approval from someone you
didn't really care never got it never
got it as a kid yeah like you got it
that was so important like to hear my
dad ever say like i just got like this
is therapy for me if you noticed this
becomes sort of therapy sometimes
but um i got a card from my dad ryan for
my birthday
and in the card
it's the first time
ever
he put i just want you to know i'm proud
of the man you've become
that's beautiful boy did it
i'm 50 years old and it nearly brought
me to tears i was like i've never heard
any of this i've never heard i'm proud
of you i'm so uh you know i'm i love you
never
and that is really difficult growing up
not hearing those things those
affirmations and
because you doubt yourself if you don't
have the ones that are taking care of
you
give you unconditional love and support
and all that
you got to find it somewhere else and so
i found it in chris pro hey you're
really good last night
so you were really good in doing sketch
comedy or whatever you did it in high
school just one show one show
that was for me the bug
and uh
yeah it's an interesting generation
though like my dad who's no longer with
us i don't know he would be 88 or
something was that a tough loss
it was many years ago now it was
probably seven years ago he was he had
battled cancer for like 10 years so we
had a good
10 years but yeah he was like the
classic
big fish salesman great talker
you know
loved to tell stories you'd hear the
same stories he was that guy a little
right but he was a wonderful character
bigger than life guy so
uh yeah
he was a big part of the whole family
right but what was the what was the 180
what was the switch from you know
because you you said you did this thing
in high school but now you're off
studying psychology
and was it an improv show or did you see
a movie or did you see something to go
you know i want to give this a shot
i took one i was so
you're you're a little braver than me
because i think i was like kind of lost
in sports i wasn't po i wouldn't
characterize myself as popular but i
could make people laugh at a party right
but i wasn't popular i wouldn't i was
like a geeky napoleon dynamite looking
kid you know what i mean
like did you get laid a lot no no god no
no
no i was very shy
very shy
and uh
the turning point i guess was like
seeing either i think i saw a touring
company a second city come through my
college
and
i think i took an acting class in
uh
my junior year in college
and i was curious to get that
affirmation from an acting teacher like
oh you're good at this
and so that was that was another turning
point because he did give me affirmation
he's like oh you're good at this which i
wanted to hear and i was you know
fortunate to hear and i wasn't brave
enough to be in acting like in greece in
high school yet like i give you credit
for that like you were like
it took a lot i was scared of [ __ ] yeah
exactly to like really commit to it and
like all my friends were jocks and i
wasn't like a meathead jock i wasn't
that
athletic but i love sports and stuff and
i love my friends but it was a different
track it would have really separated me
on a track in my mind and i don't think
i was ready for that yet so that was
part of the searching
so
and then the real thing i think is a
friend of mine my last year in college
said they teach these improv classes
downtown in chicago so i would drive my
last year college i would drive downtown
take a class and come back out to
college what was it called it was a
place called uh players workshop of
second city it was the only place
teaching improv at the time did you have
to audition for it no it was just a
class just a class they take your money
and try to teach you the fundamentals of
like
almost like viola spolan game playing
and like early theater stuff and it was
really like i said i did a variety show
i did one acting class
and then i was an improv i had very
little experience like in formal
training yet you know what i mean so
then you started to fall in love with us
i fell in love with improv which just
made me like chase it forever the idea
of creating and writing on your feet was
just mystical to me and that led me into
theater when i graduated and i was doing
psychology for the first couple years
right out of college what were you doing
in psychology i worked on an adolescent
psych ward northwestern hospital with
disturbed adolescents for two years and
i was taking like graduate school i was
thinking i was gonna be a psychologist
what was that like
it was intense it was it was really
educational and intense like a lot of
disturbed kids a lot of uh medication
that was like you know this is like 1989
let's say so like early
ritalin and early zoloft and they're
experimenting with drugs to get kids
normalized and then you'd see
schizophrenia or you'd see eating
disorders or you see kids with suicide
or you'd see like court-ordered
gang bangers who's you know the judge
says you can either go to psyche val or
you can go to prison juvie and they're
like i'll go to psyche val and then you
know so you get every kind of population
in there
wealthy
poor public aid kids you know
rockefeller kids essentially like so you
got everything in there so it was
fascinating 100
something that was too challenging that
once i was exposed to i'm like this is
too hard it was too much for you yeah
you didn't want to do it anymore because
the responsibility of helping someone
is too great like if you mess that up
they could kill themselves or they could
it could go really wrong like if you
misdiagnose if you don't get because you
saw it as i was just like on the nursing
staff as a mental health worker kind of
working my way up to like be a
psychologist i wasn't really doing
treatment plans for anyone but you
process emotion with every kid and you
try to treat them therapeutically it's
like a camp counselor vibe you know it
was draining so draining because you're
awash with pathology when you come home
at the end of the day
so that would do that during the day and
then at night i would go out and do
comedy in bars
so i had like two lessons yeah like two
i was living two days i would it was
crazy and you what was the first
the first time you felt like i'm funny
i've got this i am i how many classes in
what what happened where you felt like
i've got to go full throttle and what
did you do
the the bug or the juice that hit me or
the crack
was like i don't know three or four
classes into my first level one in
private players workshop i ended up
doing a scene with who became a friend
of mine this guy kevin ervick
and uh we like sustained a three-minute
scene that made everyone in the class
laughed and it was as if we were able to
finish each other sentences and it's as
if we knew
where the scene was going and that to me
was mind-blowing like i couldn't imagine
how that happened and so i was chasing
that i was trying to understand how to
do that again
right and when did i mean how many years
later did uh did ucb start
uh ucb probably started loosely a couple
years later like in various incarnations
and then
the four of us moved to new york and
that was amy poehler amy poehler matt
besser ian roberts and myself right
um
and then we moved to new york in like 96
in 96 and then i met michael
and then my life changed you met me you
met me in the office yeah i met you in
the office and you were like getting
coffee for dave miner i think at the
time
i probably was these uh and these guys
represent a lot of comedy studs now are
you who are you with now
uh i just have an agent i don't have a
manager anymore yeah no managers became
it's like what do you need you need a
manager do you have a manager no no but
i for years i had a manager fifteen
percent an agent ten percent a publicist
five percent a lawyer five percent it's
like what am i making any money here i
know i don't have a manager but i do
have i need an accountant like a i'm
terrible that way and i need
occasionally i get a publicist if i have
to promote something right and then an
agent you need an agent you don't you
have you must have anything i have an
agent yeah you have to have an agent
well you started i mean the likability
factor on you is really high because you
get cash can we search my likability on
the internet well is there where do you
go for that likeability.com look at
these roles like todd phillips keeps
casting you like people keep hiring you
why is that
well i think you probably have
experienced
directors or
writers who think you're sort of a muse
or someone who's like oh my god i have
this other thing michael and i'm
thinking of you todd was one of those
guys i auditioned for him once what was
that uh first one was road trip and then
also because
one of todd's co-writers was my buddy
scott armstrong who i became friends
with too
so sometimes when scott and todd were
writing they would name a character
walsh
loosely because i have an every man
quality like you can put me in a short
sleeve shirt and a tie and i look like i
belong there so
uh i think they loosely kept me there
but i would audition for walsh i've
auditioned for walsh
characters characters are named yeah
so it wasn't a gimme i had to go in and
then and then my guy in the hangover was
walsh with a v
doctor
which i don't think i had to audition
for but uh yeah so i think todd long
story short i think he just liked me
right away like and also i think
he likes improvisers and he likes
to play with it on set right and so i
was able to do that with him and i think
we had a good you know playfulness on
road trip that was the first time you
met him
i auditioned for him in a room before i
met him yeah and did you impro improvise
in the round i think i took it further i
think i went beyond what was on the page
like the scene continued and he didn't
cut it
so i think that's probably where the
improv happened i didn't feel
emboldened to just like throw the script
away and just improvise the first time i
met him what's it like being on set
and you have the scene
do you know that with a guy like todd
phillips you are going to improvise and
a lot of these guys that hire you
they're expecting matt walsh or matt
walsh to come in and bring something
bring something extra do you feel like
there's a pressure
no i don't i
personally welcome it if it's
if it's what they're looking for i want
collaboration i want to be able to
contribute to the material always i
always have plenty of ideas which i'm
never married to i don't have a big ego
like i have a much better joke put that
away i'm you know i'm
i'm pitching it in a collaborative way
uh always so i love those situations
because when you're tight
you don't
express yourself as well quite honestly
not that i can't do a scripted scene as
scripted but i also like if i understand
the character in the in the camaraderie
or the sort of artistic
jouge is there between you and the
director
then you can play in a fun way which i
think gets you a little extra right
do you ever get
nervous do you ever feel like wow
there's a lot of heavy like a court
reporter is this is he doing edit points
yeah perhaps yes perhaps okay yeah in
case something goes wrong and then i
have to like go back and say like when
would when did that go wrong i have like
well the question when i leave like oh
we need we need this again got it yeah
okay yeah it's like a court reporter i
don't i don't know if i'm depo it's like
a deposition like it's something
it's a bunch of evidence has anything
ever gone to [ __ ] oh by the way first of
all i want to know if anything has ever
gone to [ __ ] on set where you're
improvising and it's not working
nothing's working you just it can't be
funny and you feel like that just didn't
work
i feel like that's
uh
hmm
well at times it doesn't work
are when
the people sort of in charge of it don't
care like they're like just do anything
then for whatever reason
what you think is funny in the moment
doesn't work you know that's that's the
only way i can explain it so yeah
there's been times where they're like do
anything like anything like i actually
want some leadership and they're like no
no do anything like all right and then
you just give them all kinds of stuff
and then you realize like there wasn't
enough there
to
edit it into something good if that
makes sense right so you're doing a
movie essentially
and you're doing a scene and the
director really doesn't know exactly
what he wants and he's just like matt
just just do something that's a bad sign
and you that you never like that i don't
think so no like in general it doesn't
happen a lot but
sometimes
and it hasn't happened in a while but
yeah sometimes you're in those
situations like i really wish there was
something you were
giving me so like something specific
carve up or play towards that yeah and
who's the best at doing that the best at
doing what giving you specificity
any good director like lots of good like
great scripts give you specificity
obviously like if you have great scripts
and you're allowed to play a little bit
on top of them that's the dream like
right veep had that and
todd's movies have that and i've done a
lot of things with really good scripts
that you get to play with isn't it
exhausting though
you think as an actor you memorize your
lines you go in there you deliver and
you go away but a lot of times on these
shows that you see especially shows with
danny mcbride shows movies with todd
phillips judd apatow
you're going to keep doing it and you're
going to keep doing it over and over
again and
that seems like it's almost harder to
keep going to find something
as opposed to just let's get with
scripted and usually i guess when you're
filming something that's dramatic like
this new movie press play it's like matt
just deliver your lines
well that was we were in the in the
press play
me and a woman named christina chang
who's a great actor we were a couple
and we were sort of comedic relief like
we had we got to play like we were post
divorce as our timeline went on right
which i think is really funny seeing
couples who are fresh off a divorce so
we got to play a little bit comedically
but uh i i also think like
for whatever reason
drama can be more challenging
for someone or for me quite honestly
really yeah because it's
it is it's not different but it is
slightly different and it's also like
like if a director says to you
i want you to do
drunk
okay and you were playing it drunk you
did your work good actor you did your
work you know where you're at you do
some takes and then he's like i want you
to be like
spastically drunk like out of your mind
falling down drunk and you and your
heart of hearts go
that's not
that's not where i went ever like my
instinct was never that guy right right
are you gonna give it to the director
i guess you have to don't you right yeah
you do you do and do you feel in that
moment
i missed it like do you feel like shoot
i did all this investigative work on
this character
and he's got this take that i never saw
that that that means i'm a bad actor
do you have that moment
uh i've had moments where i just i'm
like wow i'm not give he wants something
completely different than what i'm
giving him so i feel like i'm failing
that happens to me in drama and that
plays on my insecurity like if i get
notes from a
director inside a drama and it's
something i missed
because i have less experience at it i
think i have less of a foundational like
integrity with it and i'm like [ __ ] i'm
a bad actor like have you gone through
those stages oh yeah oh yeah i just did
something where like the morning i'm
like i'm [ __ ] really good actor and
then the afternoon like
i don't know how to act anymore i
literally don't know how to act
i've had moments where i'm on set the
same thing where
bring anything at me give me any notes i
am on fire and then there's been times
where i'm like oh my god everybody's
looking at me i'm embarrassed i'm
terrible i want to honestly leave the
country i never should act again i just
please god get me out of this god get me
out of this god get me i swear and i'm
you're laughing but i'm really thinking
these things in my head get me out i'm
laughing because i recognize it i'm not
laughing at you sucker like you you poor
bastard i'm laughing because you could
just went through that like i get it
it's really it's hilarious because
i think it's hopefully it's just because
of experience like i have less
experience and confidence in like pure
dramatic stuff do you what i mean but do
you want to do more dramatic i do enjoy
it because i think you have that i think
you can do that i think so too and i'm
not like bragging but i think if you can
do comedy you can do drama i really like
what i think i think comedy is much
harder i do think so too and it sounds
arrogant but i do because you have like
great people like a julia dreyfus who's
like
playing this emotional moment with her
daughter and she's crying about
something let's say let's say it's a
veep episode i'm thinking of something a
moment but in the meantime she's like
don't go away because she's got another
meeting that she cares more about but
now she's back into this emotional
crying moment so she's really investing
in something emotional but i mean don't
let him leave you right yeah yeah so you
kind of have to do but you have to
ground it in reality so people get lured
into
the circumstance that you're creating
and then you also have to be able to be
funny so i don't know have you had the
moments where i'm like you're like i am
a dramatic actor wow i just nailed that
i or you watch yourself do you watch
yourself
i'm not a fan of watching myself really
i might peek at a monitor once like
coming into a project to see how they're
shooting it and see the framing and
if there's something tricky that i'm not
getting like this is what i'm doing i
really want you to like hit it here or
don't deliver that until you know then
i'll mechanically i need to know
i need to look at the monitor but
performance wise
it just puts me in a place where
you know when i do live theater i don't
look at the faces of the people watching
it
because that would put me in their head
i sort of look above their heads or i
just zone out you know what i mean and
in the same way
i can't look at my own
visage
when i'm acting because it puts me in my
head it makes me aware of like this
thing
i'm doing but if you and i are doing a
scene
i can just pretend as best i can that
it's really here but when i look at it
it takes me out of it right
so there's that do you get nervous
i do still i do
what makes you nervous
big monologues
uh shakespeare i've never done
shakespeare i don't know that i could
handle that uh big monologues how long
does it usually take you to memorize are
you a good memorizer i'm not a great if
i'm in rhythm like if i happen to be
inside a show or a movie and it's like
third week
and i got my rhythm and character
then i'll then i'll be fine but if it's
like first week or like first day and i
have the chunky monologue first day
that would terrify me that would be well
you played press secretary right yeah so
didn't you have a lot of monologues a
lot of that you could read you know it's
just like all right i got a bulletin and
then you can just have your bullets in
there right because that's what they do
they kind of like go um well
and you would do that yeah so you
wouldn't memorize them you didn't some
things you didn't have to memorize yeah
but some things you know occasionally
you have big monologues but i feel like
veep was never really in the big
monologue world very rarely it was
always like repartee and just being
bulletproof as somebody insulted you
sometimes how was it working with julie
louise dreyfus you've you've answered
this i know i had the name dropper just
so people think i'm a big deal but by
the way she's just like i i've always
had the biggest crush on her yeah i
think she's phenomenal she is she's a
force she's the best she really is she's
wonderful
kind
hilarious uh tirelessly wants it to be
amazing like she does everything right
generous
uh
a great leader you know
i think that the
thing with a show or a movie if like
number one
on the call sheet is a mess or if
they're not great then it just goes
downhill but if she's like atop the list
and she's setting the pace it just makes
everything like
you know flourish i just imagine her
always being pleasant on set hi matt how
are you good morning
i don't know that she's like a chipper
like good morning great day we're gonna
kill her today
i don't think she's she's like no no i
think she's real i think she's just real
like she's probably quiet in the morning
and worried about her lines just like we
are you know what i mean like
so
but yeah have you ever worked with an
actor where you are improvising with and
you hate this other person's skills
they are not vibing with you they are
not listening to you
and it's just going to hell and you're
like you don't know what to do and you
feel a little lost and you're hoping the
director will say something to that
person yeah i think in the in the world
of like improv if people are improvising
outside of the scene
and
they're basically doing stand-up and
they're not throwing it back at you and
they're not building something with you
that's disappointing that's like
all right you don't really need you just
turn to the director like you don't
really need me here because he's just or
she's just gonna you know
do their stand up so it's like i don't
know why i need to be here have you ever
gotten upset well yeah i guess so yeah
and then you just hope
that we don't spend too much time on it
because they're probably not going to
use a lot of it because you want to
improvise
towards the story you really want to
give them things that the editor will be
like that actually serves a story we'll
get we'll get that and sometimes you do
movies where they have you improvise all
this hilarious stuff
to an exhaustive extent which you
mentioned earlier right and then none of
it ends up in the movie is that
crushing it's not crushing but it's like
i wish they didn't make me think it was
going to be in the cut right or like
they might use it yeah yeah what do you
do in situations where because you've
you've directed you you've directed two
movies now right
and
you've also been a part of shows like
dog bites man players that were
short-lived shows that didn't last does
that is that something that kind of you
can't let go or you let it go
immediately and you said hey we did our
best or can you feel it coming
how do you deal with sort of uh failure
maybe
i guess it is hard like it is hard like
if you make a movie and it's like ah
i could have done that better i probably
won't watch it you know i can't watch it
for a while so that that is hard but you
try to
look at it and learn from it and then
with like
a show as you know like you have no
power like even if you're a celebrity
they'll cancel your show in a second so
it's just like
what you're gaining through all of it
hopefully is like a
an expertise in producing writing
uh making things better navigating the
process like experiencing all that right
so i guess you just try to take away
whatever experience you can get from
those things but it yeah i mean it is
disappointing and it is hard sometimes
you
you can
yeah you can like lick your wounds a
little long i guess who what's the one
thing that you had to do that where
you're like you know i have to i'm this
is gonna take me a minute to get over
what is the thing that make me get over
i don't know
i'm trying to think that's a really good
question uh put that on the list to get
back to you right get back because
there's a multi-task i mean i really
i'll multitask like
the thing that really
beyond like some girl that broke up with
me when i was like twenty-two anything i
mean i've had that i've had i've had
that too sure like i had a show that i
did it lasted two years it was uh decent
ratings uh reviews were pretty good and
then they cancelled it and they just
said this is not what our network is
looking for and i remember going hey
thanks for the work appreciate it and i
didn't think it bothered me i thought i
was good with it
and then all of a sudden i just felt
like
man that was a really good gig i was
really lucky to be a part of that
and it just got kind of got down like
what was it is it me i guess so i'm the
lead
you know you start to doubt yourself and
uh have you done that
yeah i guess i can't think of a specific
project or maybe i'm too guarded about
it maybe you're too great no no no i i
have those moments but like
i don't know the thing that like i
probably hung on to too long i think is
what you're describing
i don't know i can't think of it that's
all right yeah i mean by the way
do you remember because you remember
specifically when your parents came to
the worst shows ever
do you remember when they came to a show
where you were like [ __ ]
yeah
well it was always things that they
would appreciate like if i did
a british mystery show my mom would be
in heaven like she would be like that's
the premium
entertainment
there could possibly be
it's like an interesting detective
who has a british accent who's solving a
mystery every week oh my god my mom
would just be like i'd be your favorite
child did you do that a lot that
character huh
i've never done it but i haven't i've
never done it oh i thought maybe it's
something that you know
because i want to see that character no
i i
sometimes think i should write a mystery
just to please my mom because she's
always watching british shows she's
always watching mysteries so
in some ways i'll never measure up to
her like sense of what
you know exalted
theater can do or exalted television
like she's kind of like veep but i think
she might have found it a little vulgar
at times
or whatever or it wasn't her cup of tea
perhaps was there something though that
she was like i really you were great
i can't think of it you know god damn it
i'm serious too like i but you know
i like you perhaps didn't really get it
like i wasn't gonna get it from that
generation like
yeah i think it's of the school of like
oh if you tell your kids you love them
too much they'll be soft
they'll be like they won't be hungry
they won't be ambitious they got to be
toughing up and make it on their own or
something you know what i mean there's a
little
whatever that eisenhower error mentality
is that bled into all of our you know
upbringing perhaps there wasn't that
elevated understanding of that you know
speaking love and
doing that for people is really valuable
and it won't tarnish them and it won't
make them soft so
i don't know that i ever got like my
mom's raving review and she kept
bringing up but i do remember the things
that like just doing a commercial early
on where she could tell her friends
matt's on a commercial like she liked
being able to see things that her
friends could see do you know what i
mean yeah so if it's like if it's a
commercial for true value he's on that
troop he was on a super bowl commercial
he's that commercial was not like she
loved doing that she likes to have
things so really anything
that wasn't
i don't know r-rated that she could tell
her friends about she probably liked now
is there something because i know you
don't watch yourself a lot
but is there something you could at
least appreciate now you watch it
there's like you know when you when you
came up in a movie in a todd phillips
movie or the hangover or something where
you you just killed it and it's
something that you go you know what you
could at least look at that and say
matt
you nailed it
you're funny you're really funny in that
well
i don't really go back to my work ever
like i think i watch everything once or
i haven't yet
and uh maybe when i'm 80 and we're in
the olf hoax home for motion picture
actors we'll we'll do it michael you and
i all right uh but
mike uh i did i'm one of those guys
who's doing a re-watch podcast me too
okay it started uh wednesday called
talkville it's about rewatch smallville
i'm doing one with tim simons called
second in command which will we did the
first half we'll be coming back soon
enough
spite that has caused me
to go through every episode of veep
and i'm like oh i did a good job i like
that real performance yeah i don't hate
it like i know and i and i also can
watch
everything like i can watch other people
and like because i think as an actor
sometimes you're myopic and you're like
i gotta get this monologue writer i
gotta get this scene writer i gotta get
like you know what i mean so you're
you're a little
just focused on your scene and then you
see this beautiful show
when it's all packaged together and you
can really enjoy it as a fan like i'm
sure you can watch
the whole show now
and not just see yourself but like oh my
god yes he was great she was great yeah
and not that you didn't appreciate other
people before but i think we're
burdened with our nervousness to
deliver and some of that comes from
insecurity some of that comes from ego
some of that is just like it's human
beings trying to do a good job and
everybody has that right so it's
refreshing to go like five years after
whatever the last episode of veep was
out to go back through the first i think
we've gone through the first three and
watch them and not feel
anything but like wow that's a great
show that was really good and and to
also
literally be removed and watch it as a
fan is amazing well you have guests on
that show yes we do we try to get
every week we'll try to get
anybody that who came through the show
one of the regulars tony's been on
julia's been on
sam's been on is that a lot of fun to go
back it is
it is do they actually go back and watch
or they you don't no we don't watch we
just sort of have talking points and
we'll hit the plot and then we'll just
go anywhere subject matter can go
anywhere we just have it be a
conversation you ever been intimidated
by someone you're working with
yeah
i'm trying to think like any big actor
came on set and you're like oh [ __ ]
these are big pointed questions um
names names names and names
intimidated well i think cue laurie
coming into veep was a big moment for me
i was intimidated by him because he's a
consummate amazing
dramatic comedic guy yeah
uh there was also a director named chris
morris i don't know if you know him no
he directed these really subversive
shows called the brass eye and he was
sort of uh
i was way
uh intimidated by him because he has
this very aggressive almost like sasha
baron cone prank style comedy that was
an early
probably influenced sasha and a lot of
stuff that happened over here so he was
just
someone i was intimidated by those are
two names that come to mind who are the
best improvisers that you see out there
now that you i mean obviously there's a
ton of great improvisers but who are the
ones that you're like these are my
favorite well
there's like guys like old school guys
like a guy dave pasgrazie who is always
great because he when i started i was a
freshman he was a senior at the second
city sort of pool of talent
and he's kind of like
a good dramatic actor but he's really
good improviser so he's someone that
like i have a lot of respect for still
or that i know
still improvises and is really great um
i think a lot of the guys i just play
with are great like i don't know like
anybody that's uh
i don't really improvise anymore
actually because
that's you know just not something i
have time for or with the theater we
don't do the theater anymore but it's
still around upright citizens well we
don't have anything to do with it no we
don't no we don't have nothing to do
with it when did you let that go
during covid
shut down
and there was that hard yeah that was a
hard one
yeah we had to get rid of it that was a
hard one when you say like things that
like
ended and you're like uh i wish i could
have made that last longer or i wish was
it me you know i had to do some
examining around that and also when i
put it down i'm like oh thank god that
was a nightmare headache to manage
because it was like 20 years we were
trying to keep a theater afloat what do
you miss about it what do you miss about
the gym night show the pickup shows the
sunday night improv with people
just doing a goo it's like pick up
basketball it's like amazing it really
keeps you fresh and smart and you laugh
your ass off and it's good for your
health you like literally expand your
lungs and
and you also creatively
chase these premises that you would
never
come up with on your own right what's
next what else are you doing you got
press play oh zach woods is a great
improviser he's someone that zach woods
yeah he's he's so eloquent yeah so
what's next
what's you gotta got the podcast we got
the second in command second in command
promotion promotion uh you gotta promote
you gotta no no i know you're right uh i
should start bragging about myself
i just finished this show called
which isn't coming back but it's called
um
it's on the cw which you're probably
familiar with the network
uh would i lie to you it was like a fun
panel show where two teams tried to lie
to each other that was a blast i shot
that but that's gone
um
what the hell is going on there's a
movie called unplugging that's
out on demand now you can watch i wrote
it and co-starred it with uh eva
longoria oh wow yeah really proud of you
you directed it no no just uh wrote it
co-starred uh
with eva we play a couple who puts their
devices down for a weekend and just it
goes bananas they can't handle it is it
hard being a writer when someone else is
directing you when you have written the
the stuff
depending on the direct if the director
thinks
they're a better writer than you
then it is hard but if you get a
director who's like collaborative and
like sort of defers to some moments that
like you guys probably have this then it
works great if they're focused on other
things like visuals and
things like that if it's collaborative
basically right
all right this is called [ __ ] talking
with matt walsh this is uh these are my
patrons
go to patreon.com inside of you to
support the podcast these these folks do
it and they get to ask some questions
and i appreciate you thanks become a
patron i'll write you back
uh these are
fast you can just spit them out if you
want these are questions from your
questions friends my patrons yeah your
patrons the people who support the show
support the podcast got it so they get
to ask some questions so we just
narrowed it down
thank you and these are the questions
for you you didn't do it i'm sure ryan
did this uh you know you didn't do
anything what are you talking about you
just rolled in i am really you made me
coffee you were a good host i'm a reader
okay you're reading it
leanne veep any funny behind-the-scenes
stories you would like to share did you
take any props home from set
uh
i kept my watch so mike wore a watch in
every episode and i it was actually a
watch my grandpa gave me so i took that
back
and then i have a giant
uh i don't know it's like a 200-pound
piece of plexiglass that says cbs news
with mike mcclintock
and dave mandel the head writers like
who's a total memorabilia geek he saves
star wars gear he has like a me too look
at
him
yeah he has like a boba fett mask and he
has like a raiders of the lost ark you
know clip from whatever what's this
called this thing what do you call this
thing when you go take two what's that
called uh
uh what do you call this slate slate
he has an original from like raiders and
stuff wow he's like you got to keep this
thing i'm like it's like 200 pounds and
it's like eight feet by eight feet and
he's like you gotta do i'm like all
right i guess so he arranged and i had
the prop guy delivered to my house i
don't know what i'm gonna do with it but
i have that leanne
emily asks what's been your most
favorite role to do so far in your
career
well this is such a cop-out but i love
any role that i can help write so
anything from
veep to sketches and upright citizens
brigade to dog bites man to todd
phillips movies like you know
anything where i'm able to like
contribute i'm super psyched about
awesome michelle k matt since you're a
chicago native deep dish regular or thin
crust pizza then
all right
kelly s i think you're hysterical
kelly you did a great job on veep how
many times did you have to redo a scene
because you burst out laughing
just a couple i got pretty good at not
laughing but just a couple is there
someone who does does she laugh a lot
julia
julia little no julia's pretty pro she
tries to like tony was weak
tim could be weak
um those would be the two gigglers
probably that come to mind does it upset
you when you're just killing something
and it's so funny and people are
laughing
no i'm a fan of the i i love a good just
burst out like i love a good gag reel i
love a good crack up like that's
so much joy
i don't get mad
unless we were like blowing up a car and
we only had one car
and then they laughed and ruined it then
i guess i'd be mad but
ultimately it's just dialogue we can get
we'll get it you know all right danny
what has been the busiest year of your
life to date and how did you manage it
i feel like in the veep years when we
were like doing seasons back to back and
like maybe flying to baltimore and then
coming home and like were you exhausted
yeah it felt like and it sounds
ungrateful but it felt like a
[Music]
the the sort of uh
you know the party scene not the party
scene like this sounds like cocaine but
like emmys isn't just the emmys it's
like the parties around the emmys and if
you get nominated you're doing that and
then you're doing publicity for that and
so
some of those seasons in the middle
i found really hectic and wonderfully
grateful for all of it
ray h what do you consider your greatest
accomplishment
ray h i have a buddy named rage i wonder
if it's my greatest accomplishment it's
a woman
ray is a woman okay sorry oh how sexism
is kelly a woman or a man
uh kelly is a woman okay
um
my biggest accomplishment greatest
accomplishment greatest accomplishment
without saying your kids and your wife
yeah that's a good one that's that's
that's where i would go yeah
[Music]
pass
you want to pass on that one well i'm
sorry ray like
because i feel like that you're just a
matter of fact pass
yeah okay i'm not gonna be cornered on
that one
because this goes down in the historical
record this podcast will live for
infinity my kids will stumble on it and
they'll be like why didn't you say me or
why don't you say this do your kids
think you're funny
a little bit
a little bit a little bit yeah they're
fun i think they probably think i'm
corny or something is your wife funny
morgan she is funny she is funny she
makes you laugh she does
do you make her laugh
i do still to this day and you've been
married how long
i don't know how long we've been 13
years 13 years we've been married been
together 17.
uh yeah i still make her laugh how do
you know when you were with the right
one
oh my god
what is it what is this from you or from
the list this is from me man are you
married can i ask you some questions
you're not ask me anything you want are
you settled are you with someone no
what's the longest long-term relation a
couple years
two years
and
with that two-year
with i'm sure i'm assuming you probably
had a couple two-year relationships yes
sure
what was it about those two that made
you stay in it what was special about
those two
um i just felt really comfortable like i
could just be me like i could really
just be the [ __ ] lazy shitty me
you felt you could be honest i did and i
lost those people those women those
great women but
it was my own problem my own fault
but
i answered my own question i've i've had
opportunities i just need to
not let another one pass me up i guess
but what do you know what is it about
you in a relationship that makes you
feel like
morgan's right for me
i think it's luck i think the
serendipity of like meeting someone at
the right time is what it's about i
think like the fact that
morgan and i are still together and we
have three kids and you know we're
probably be knocking one will be
together forever um i think it's
the luck of meeting each other when both
of you
are relatively healthy
and willing to be your ugly selves
that's what it is i think for me it was
and i think probably for her because she
had her [ __ ] together too
and i don't know that i had my [ __ ]
together but i was also kind of over
trying to be someone else
and so i think that plays because that
creates momentum
and then
once you're in it and you're invested in
it and you realize like oh she's got my
back and like ah i am i should probably
work on myself and
then you like then the momentum carries
you but like the beginning and like the
awesomeness of it all i think you have
to get a little lucky and with where
you're at and where what the other
person's at i do i think that's the
biggest
for me that's what made a difference
yeah
and you've shown her your ugly colors oh
my god i
every day jesus
she's a little disappointed she's
probably regretting it at this point
she's like oh my god oh come on i knew
you were ugly but not this nasty
uh christy last question what's your
biggest pet peeve
that's a good question christy pet
peeve
these are ticky tacky but
one is
you know when you're like
getting off the plane
and it parks
and then they gotta like unlock the door
and they gotta secure the things and tie
the handles down and then you can get up
and leave and
and you see people like
race up
and cut in front
and just like they want to be the first
as if they're the only ones who have a
busy day ahead of them
and the truth is like they might take
five spot they might get up five rows
but they're gonna wait two you know what
i mean that's just something that like
i'm such a small
person and i realized too like sometimes
people do have a connecting flight and
i don't know but it just it's just one
of those like human nature things i'm
like that just bugs me i'm like do you
really first of all you're not really
you might get four rows you might get
three you're not getting mine well no
you're not
you're not getting
mine no you're not i'll get my bag out
there
i'll get my body out there and i'll just
be like
i guess we'll wait until the door opens
and sometimes it's
not even for me it's for other people
like they're cutting off other people
it's not i'm not so like you don't do
this to me i'm like everybody's in this
i think that's very fair that irks me
too right i think that's yes i think
you're absolutely right yeah
so
yeah and then like uh
just not a fan of carl's jr in general
it's a pet
make it right or don't do it
i don't know it's just there's nothing
there that came out of left field
that was great
this has been a real treat for me i feel
like i got to know you
i appreciate you for coming on the
podcast thanks for allowing me to be
inside of you today whoa i mean that's
how we roll that's personal i didn't
know you were going to get inside me but
i felt you were gentle yes i tried to be
you were trying to be ryan did you get
all this i did got all of it anything we
need to go back on
uh greatest accomplishment no
you remember i believe it was the
greatest accomplishment uh
i met michelle obama once i don't know
did you really yeah we met her uh
between
the west wing and something she was
running between buildings in dc was she
sweet yeah she was lovely brief so
so brief but she was lovely i love it
yeah i love well thanks for coming on
the podcast thank you for having me all
right
now i'm gonna take in your room we're
done
yeah i uh i enjoyed that
yeah
so funny so funny so naturally funny and
and open and you know just hearing
different perspectives from different
people about their life and how they
handle things and how they handle stress
and how they how they started and you
know he uh
he wasn't uh he didn't think he was
gonna get into comedy and he didn't get
into it till late
and uh it's a great story so thank you
um also thank you for listening to the
podcast and if you want to become a
patron go to patreon.com
inside of you
and uh join the family join the family
of patrons who support this podcast and
i'll send you a message soon right after
you join and um a lot of perks and cool
stuff there and of course the inside of
online store
merch and uh i'll be in boston this
weekend with tom welling 12th 13th and
14th doing the smallville nights
and uh signing autographs and it's
always nice to see you guys see your
faces there
um
and part of the great perk of being a
patron is the the shout outs at the end
of the episode and that's what we do now
we give shout outs to everybody the top
tiers who give the most to the podcast
and that's what we're gonna do right now
and and and uh ryan's got it pretty much
memorized oh yeah
do you think you still have it memorized
nope no
there's some new ones uh nancy d leah
sarah v little lisa you kiko jill e
brian h nico p robert c
nope
close
uh b robert b jason w sophie
r m
raj c j joshua d c j p jennifer and s n
n and that's it
you did stacy l jamal
s janelle
b kimberly
e mike e
eldon supremo el dan supremo 99 more ra
mira santiago emma chad
w you're right leanne
p and maya p maddie s belinda n chris
h dave h sheila g brad d rey h tabitha t
tom
and liliana
a yes
talia
n
m m correct betsy d chad d
l
l marion meg k angel
f m m rhiannon c corey
c k k dev nexon michelle
k a
jeremy c andy
d t
gavin nader
david r c
john
c b brandy
l d
for camille
n
s
the c joey
fatone joey fatone joey m design
otg eugene and
uh leah nikki
p
g
these are the tough ones these are the
bottoms yeah we're getting into some
into some all right it's corey
uh kdb patricia heather l jake b megan t
male s you did really good really really
good mel s orlando c caroline r
christine sarah s eric h jennifer r
shane r m r jeremy v andrew m robert g
zatoychi 77 cool i just talked to
satoichi on the patron i know i messed
it up again andreas n alexandra chris r
michael f samantha w
michael michelle d and amanda
r
and those are the top tier patrons those
of you who really helped the podcast uh
appreciate you good talking to you on
the patreon last night
and uh or maybe it was last week because
this is recorded a little later but um
hey i i really appreciate you
thanks for supporting the podcast um
[Music]
i guess that's it ryan i guess that's it
for today a lot of great guests coming
up though all right yeah a little tired
today yeah yeah yeah
yeah just a little out of it yeah you
know we got another podcast to record
you know new month new month new month
um but it's all good it's all gonna be
good tomorrow's a new day make the most
of today um
[Music]
from
the hollywood hills
in california i am michael rosenbaum
i'm still ryan taylors yeah a little
wave to the camera we love you guys
thanks for being you be good to yourself
and we'll see you next week thank you
for listening
[Music]